hi is this great volume through field
gun I can't see any of you really
directly so affair with me firstly I am
so excited to get to be here I was told
this event is 75 percent women my glance
at your very dark spaces suggests that
maybe it's even more so I'm Erin I
founded a company called Clara labs
Clara is an intelligent assistant that
helps do menial work that you would
otherwise have to manage on your own and
we are very very big on empowering women
tomorrow's International Women's Day
encourage your company be content
they'll be awesome so as I was preparing
for the talk today I was trying to think
about the things in my life that had
brought me to you guys in the first
place right I'm 25
when I was 20 I did not have some
perfect vision or perfect path that told
me that on this day and time in the
future I would be giving a talk about my
company that builds in artificial
intelligence that you can talk with that
was not really in the cards for me so I
wanted to tell you a story that could
have wind back to when I was 20 and the
the narrative that has brought me to all
of the successes and happinesses that I
that I have had as of yet when I was 20
I got an internship I spent a summer in
New York City and I'm from Texas I was
you know studying psychology and
neuroscience and young great hook em
horns for any of you who went to UC and
getting to spend a summer in New York
with this kind of dream I had over the
course of the past several years to
fallen in love with the idea of building
technology of being a technologist
coming from a humanities background
coming from really loving people the
idea that you could build things that
people would work with every day just
really I fell in love with head over
heels I started to see human beings as
technologists right to create all these
theories about
teacher and I became convinced outside
of knowing any venture capitalist at all
that the way that I was supposed to
become a technologist was might be
coming up in sure capitalist right to be
there in the weed they had this whole
vision in the trenches with the founders
building this company is going to be so
great and so in my time in New York I
was lucky enough to build a relationship
with one venture capitalist a man named
Charlie O'Donnell who founded a fund
called Brooklyn British ventures and the
last day that I was in New York were
getting coffee and I told him Charlie
you know I'm very smart I have lots of
great qualities of I very interested in
being a venture capitalist out of
undergrad
kado Ikeda's and his response to me was
like marin there are only perhaps two
people a year who become the seeds out
of undergrad you just don't have a big
enough network to be valuable to a
venture firm to which I
reanima kind of immediately here and I'm
walking away and getting into the subway
thinking okay Charlie didn't just tell
me no he just told me that in the next
nine months I need to somehow build a
big enough network of people such that I
am valuable to a venture capital firm I
ended up founding a community called
interact you're welcome to go to join
interact calm if you're curious about it
of a hundred young technology that come
together every year and meet and build
relationships with each other because
they like me often haven't built big
networks of people who help them see
their dreams through and who connect
them to their next opportunities connect
them to the
has been the careers in the life that
they're that they are aspiring to and
the impact that they're aspiring to it
was an unbelievably challenging
community to build the first person who
rejected me after Charlie approximately
20 minutes later right as I got in the
subway having thought about this was my
best friend Michael Italian right I call
him I'm like we're going to bring 100
people too often it's going to be the
best they're all going to South by brain
get badges for everybody we're going to
host everybody 100 people in Austin
South by Southwest will be really easy
well you know six or seven events super
super chill
he was just like marrying this idea is
stupid this is never working I think
though back to that first weekend and to
having been able to build that first
community of people and the number of
nodes that it took to get to to get to
that moment to get to that group of
people how absolutely spectacular and
impressive every single one of them was
and how much they've all changed my life
and how much that community has changed
each other's lives and the things that I
remember of course is that by that point
in time I was no longer actually
interested in being a venture capitalist
right my my path and my ambition had
changed I went on to get a lot of jobs
to work in venture but having built
interact having gotten all the nodes
having read $50,000 in sponsorship
having thought that I was going to have
to take out a $20,000 personal loan
having promised a million things to a
million people and really carrying all
that weight I became convinced that the
thing that I wanted to do was to build
something myself and that I had the
capacity to to do that and so my dream
changed right my dream change in a
really big way and I subsequently ended
up sounding not just Clara but another
company that's already failed
lots of failures behind me oh so I think
the things I wanted to share with you
guys
is much better said by a woman that I
loved named Maya Angelou now I'm going
to directly quote her and not watch it
she says you may encounter many defeats
but you must not be defeated in fact it
may be necessary to encounter the
defeats so you can know who you are what
you can rise from and how you can still
come out of it if there's anything that
I could do and having talked to all
these awesome women who are very smart
and very articulate backstage before
this if there's anything that I think
any of us could encourage you to do it
and encourage ourselves to do and remind
ourselves of it would be to remind you
to take your dreams just desperately
seriously and to take your your lives
very seriously I think that it is a gift
to get to find something that matters
enough to you that it's worth rejection
right something that is a vision that
you have to see through such that you
are excited about being told no hundreds
of times because I think that those
visions right those things that we want
to hear know for that we accept the news
for are the things that make us each
have come alive and I think that that's
just one of the greatest gifts that we
get to have as people and one of the
things that we should share and
encourage in each other so celebrate
International Women's Day tomorrow
remember Maya Angelou if you ever if you
ever need support and please just if
there's something that you want and
you're told no don't think that you have
to know the perfect path to the thing
that you're trying to get you don't you
just have to know that you care enough
about some
that no is an accessible answer in most
cases not all
[Applause]